he's played really well today eric
hansen it was just maybe two bad moves
in the last game that swung things he
was actually winning and uh two three
moves later he was just checkmated out
of the blue out of nowhere so keep doing
what he's doing eric and he will have a
chance we do meanwhile see the spanish
opening and a variation of the
anti-berlin so not the berlin defense
not the berlin endgame or the berlin
draw that we're used to seeing quite
recently among top players eric keeping
peace on the board keeping the tension
not allowing too many trades early anish
meanwhile trying to crack open the
center trying to trade pawns and uh he
knows the draw is enough for him as
black he's chosen one of the most solid
openings out there so eric he's an
expert with one e4 he's been playing it
his whole career can he keep the tension
can he outplay gary from this very
symmetrical position right now that is
the question
it's uh level-ish but still a lot of
tension and what is it about for a niche
then he only needs a draw but we have
seen some bad situations when you play
too much on the draw right
yeah simon what would you recommend
playing for a draw is the hardest thing
in the world right yeah i i think you
have to play a normal game but you've
got to play for the win it sounds a bit
odd but you can't play for the draw
when you need to draw don't play for the
draw
which is just weird right it's the
paradox you've got to actually just be
sensible and take your chances still put
the pressure on your opponent you're
much more likely to get a draw that way
yeah if you play principal chess you
will get a chance later on in the game
to maybe trade some pieces or maybe
repeat the position or go on an attack
where uh at the very minimum you'll be
able to bail out with a draw so if yeah
you're completely right it's i've been
there myself needing a draw sometimes
for a grand master normal to win a
tournament and going to
kind of too single-mindedly in that
direction it will backfire so okay a
trade of another set of pawns here and
uh eric captured away from the center
look at the white dart square bishop on
a nice diagonal gary however the clock
times dictate that
he's pretty much in his preparation i'm
a little bit surprised that this
exchange happened because it has allowed
eric to unbalance the structure even a
little bit kind of helps him in a
must-win situation uh did a niche really
need to to capture there so quickly
i'm not sure um but he does seem to know
what he's doing doesn't he's played b5
and okay he's moving very quickly
quickly and actually that pawn capture
that we saw a few moves ago that was
totally new never been played before
everyone else had been playing more like
you
does seem to have it all worked out at
least judging by clock times yeah yeah
we know from his games but also his
chessable courses uh anishi is one of
the leading experts one of the uh in
openings one of the leading
theoreticians do you think we'll see
yeah these days do you think we see a
chess ball course from magnus on one f3
potentially maybe you can do a joint one
with him you know 20 hour videos
how impressive is that actually to
survive when the first move you make
against one of the best players in the
world is one f3 it is it is pretty
impressive actually because you know the
1f3 is kind of like a joke opening you
know i do know a story about the england
top juniors they had like an account
online and uh their whole goal with this
porn move was actually to get their king
as far up the board as it could possibly
go without getting checkmated and then
dash back down again and uh such bad
habits yeah such bad habits these days
but you know they they worked on this a
little bit you know where the king could
go and they got to quite a high rating
but it is like a joke
you don't you don't do it you know for a
serious game of chess and you certainly
don't do it you know in your match
situation either
and we normally talk about the white
pieces you have a small advantage in the
opening because you can choose the type
of position but i think f3 is the only
way or one of the only ways you can
guarantee that you have a disadvantage
from move one i think it probably is the
worst move on move one i can't i can't
think of a you know a worse option than
one f3 because it weakens your king
takes away square for the night gives
away it just gives away everything
doesn't it sounds like terrible the
whole thing is um actually probably
taking a square from the night yeah
that's probably what makes it so you
can't develop you can't castle easily it
is recognized opening to push the f-pawn
two squares forward yeah yeah
and meanwhile we see giri at the front
of our picture but also liam and his
position uh in the background there
giri just playing a really good move
there bringing his rook across just
peeking over liam's screen looks pretty
balanced but uh yeah giri just bringing
his rook across he's getting ready to
push the black sea pawn forward two
squares uh eric meanwhile bringing his
queen forward and there we go black
seaport does indeed push forward he's
just trying to initiate maximum uh
trades here he's just trying to exchange
off as many pawns as possible we said
don't play straight for the draw but
gary's doing that and yeah but he's he's
doing it in a semi clever way because i
mean he could have pushed he potentially
sacrificing that b pawn he he's you know
he knows what he's doing at least here
so yeah
yeah he knows what he's doing because
after this pawn is recaptured either by
the black rook or by the black dark
square bishop
yes black's e pawn in the middle of the
board might even fall but white's a pawn
on the left side also about to be picked
off so it's just gonna
kind of transition into a position where
lots of pieces have disappeared maybe
pawns will disappear as well and
eric just not left with enough firepower
yeah it's a good opening choice by anish
i have to say you know the position is
very open that when the when all the
pawns have been traded off the more
pieces that get traded off like you say
it's going to be what is eric doing he's
scrolling down his playlist i think he's
choosing a song
getting the priorities right so uh can
we get a close-up off his screen oh crap
milliseconds too slow there
but uh meanwhile a trade of a set of
pawns and this is the type of position
where you do really need to get pumped
you need to the creative juices to start
flowing because it's so balanced yes the
evaluation bar's on white side i'm
slightly surprised it's that far on
white side but uh you need something
because if those two pawns on the left
side of the board if black speed porn
and white's apon both disappear as well
it's just complete symmetry
yeah play will switch to one side of the
board and it should be a draw i mean the
one one thing i'm seeing is that all of
black's piece is at least over on the
queen side you know so you can see the
black king come on let's let's try
signal let's try to launch towards the
black king somehow i mean i i guess i'm
thinking bishop takes pawn first to open
that one up and just unbalance the
structure uh but you've got these knight
h4 ideas are very typical as well at the
right moment um i don't think it's a
good move here but this kind of idea is
typical for for the royal lopez in
general
but i guess maybe bishop takes pawn and
just uh you know get that one in the
game yeah and uh i guess black will
reply to this by capturing another pawn
yeah and uh black does have a past pawn
but it's a slightly weak uh attacking
white's rook as well yeah what about
here simon trade or maybe dodge maybe
you gain a bit of time if you trade at
least yeah yeah and this is where you
need a a big move isn't it or to put
some pressure on your opponent one idea
could be just retreating this bishop i'm
not sure where maybe back one square or
even can win a pawn here can't you i
mean oh can you maybe not because of
bishop a6 but i think if you take the
knight take on b5 but that's probably
not gonna be enough to win and there is
a little cheeky move at the end of that
that black can play as well all the
trades whites are pawn up but at the
very basics yeah some tricks skewer here
um i was going to say the other
alternative if you're not trying to play
greedy is just retreat and at least now
it's imbalanced in a must-win situation
imbalancing the pawn structure is
important and you do have an idea of
pushing forward with that one maybe
opening up your bishop i like this
because look at the bishops then and the
black king this is kind of this is the
kind of thing you need as white the the
attack as we said right at the start for
example
one more move i mean suddenly this
bishop gets opened up the other bishop
supports it on this diagonal uh pointing
towards the black king so maybe we're
not giving eric enough credit here i
think he's doing okay maybe gary yeah
yeah it's uh maybe gary rushing too fast
towards that draw and uh in the current
position here uh we're expecting gary to
go and capture this pawn because he is
temporarily uh one
uh of these foot soldiers down so if he
captures the spawn a rook trade this is
what we're expecting the white bishop to
jump out of the way and then to just
launch this pawn forward launch the
attack against the black king and just
hope that that pays off
it looks nice looks nicer white actually
okay oh he didn't retreat his bishop i
thought that was maybe the key maybe the
way to go he brought his rook to that
square instead but what's the idea here
bishop takes knight yes it's the first
one isn't it is that even so great for
example even if i allow it if i push
this pawn forward if you trade okay here
i can take with the queen but even if
you get this pawn structure oh maybe you
can go hard
whoa i'm still skeptical but really
i'll just plant my king in the corner i
don't know okay well maybe maybe
this is the type of position where we'd
have a battle and simon would try and
checkmate me i would just try and curl
up into a ball and survive
and then i'd resign five days later so
yeah yeah so if we come back to the
current position this is maybe a threat
bishop takes knight because uh for
example if black just makes a random
move now the queen can't take because
this bishop would just fall
so uh trying to ruin the black pawn
structure
still interesting i mean all the white
pieces are in the middle they've got a
lot of potential so um
yeah lots playful and speaking of
interesting
we do have a question from luffy on
twitter who asks us
how do we prepare
for the before for them
i'll start again luffy asks us how do
you prepare yourself before each live
broadcast
um
that is a good question
lots of lots of um water you know the
normal kind of thing trying to do a bit
of uh you know a bit of information on
what the players are going to do have an
idea what's happening and
yeah and then stress out you know yeah
for round one but the tension but no no
it's a lot of fun yeah and just try to
keep it light and enjoy and enjoy the
time here i think is important so yeah
yeah um i try and do a bit of research
on the players look at their
head-to-head scores look at some
openings that they play or their
favorite openings maybe um and today for
example i played some sports uh earlier
today just to kind of loosen up
and uh get the blood flowing i mean we
do start the broadcast very late the
players i mean they start their games
very late in the day so you need to
train yourself you don't want to wake up
at 6 00 a.m in the morning because
imagine starting the games at 6 00 p.m
uh oslo time they'll be exhausted so
it's all about adapting making sure
you're fully focused and you peak at the
right time
and i do remember there was a an
interview that pragnanda did um after he
defeated magnus and they asked him you
know what was your training and he said
because he was playing so late at night
could spend weeks
playing at one o'clock in the morning
just to get the mind ready for chess is
going to happen in the evening you have
to be sharp by then and uh yeah so
preparation is key this is morning for
pragnanda he's used to playing the
multiplayer champions chester at 10 11
midnight
and in oslo right now the clock is 9 p.m
but it all starts at 6 p.m
so
you know
late but uh early for uh pragnanda yeah
exchange he seems to thrive
at that time winning his match in three
games
yeah eerie and age geary strikes me as a
morning person i don't know though
i reckon he's got two kids yeah exactly
so they're going to be waking up at
silly o'clock i've got one cat which
normally wakes me up at like
five or six so it's in the morning in
the morning yeah so it's like okay i'm
up you know
i'm a bit of a morning person now i
never used to be but uh yeah
so and how is charlie coping when you're
in also simon he's been well looked
after i'm sure very very well spoiled so
and you know he's got his nice garden
and a bit son he's doing all right he's
doing well i'm glad you're here yeah
charlie how old is he charlie he's old
he's like 18 19 now so
yeah he's an old old ginger cat so
still doing all right though so yeah
he's you know healthy
healthy healthy cat wow yeah big ginger
legendary gets into fights i've been
following uh since well we've had two
cats i don't know what i'm talking about
cats but i've got to continue now we've
had we've had two cats move on to the
hood
from afghanistan so they're a bit
gangster style because
yeah they've come refugee cats so the
person adopted them so they're trying to
like you know put their stamp on the on
the territory so yeah there's some
there's some warfare going on as i speak
properly
and charlie's taking the hits he he no
no he's standing his ground okay you
know so yeah
there we go
cat drama
fight this game yeah nice this is
shaping up to be okay players are being
territorial both players are standing
their ground yeah especially eric i
think he's not backing down from that
fight because he did give up the bishop
pair something i'm really reluctant to
do he did we did see a bishop for night
trade but that gained eric the time to
push upon forward and now he's hitting
the black queen the black queen has to
move but more importantly white's light
squared bishop has opened up a path now
towards the black king so
gary has to be a bit careful where he
places his queen there's not too many
safe squares
um i would be inclined to maybe shift it
across two squares just to keep the
black king nice and safe but
once the black queen moves eric can play
for an attack maybe utilizing that uh
light square diagonal or he can play
position e just trade off the light
square bishops bring the light square
bishop to the middle and uh okay there
we go it's more important to get the
playlist right what's yes what song are
you choosing
what's he going for oh he's scrolling
through all of it
okay he's ch oh
we can see what is the name dvc
avicii maybe was it avicii oh i think
the twitter uh our twitter yes viewers
might have to help us uh work out what
that was what that song was
yeah
it might have been avicii uh and we do
know he likes that kind of music eric
right a little bit pumped up yeah i i
don't know i suspect it might be like
some trance type of
music or techno
so something that he can just
get himself
ready and fight him he's bouncing to it
bouncing to it he's getting in the fight
actually actually caught a dvs one
okay i feel old now i don't know what
that is some techno song i'm sure v s
one i mean anyone who's watched the
chess bar chess bra stream knows that uh
eric amman all the chess bras out there
they this is their yeah this is their
jam this is what they uh get pumped on
and yeah this kind of gives them the
rhythm especially with blitz chests and
rapid chess as well to an extent well
look at me in the rhythm look at the
valuation bar i mean it's jumped and i
was i was going to say these positions
where white has that pawn in the middle
uh on that square that dark square i
love playing these positions with the
white white side because i think it was
uh you mentioned max uber who said when
you've got a pawn there you attack the
king and this is what eric needs to do
he just needs to attack the king is
there a big move here though is there
some tactic after this move uh some way
he can you know go straight for the king
now um still not 100 obvious isn't it is
there some kind of
tactic with the i'm just thinking that
night uh that is sitting there on the a7
square
and i'm just i'm yeah so i'm just uh i'm
inspired by that game that um pragananda
played by jordan i'm trying to think
loose pieces drop off tactical
weaknesses and i see that the bishop was
also a tactical weakness so i'm just
thinking maybe you just slide your queen
one square forward and attack the knight
hitting this knight with the rook and
with the queen yeah and another idea is
to actually within that is knight takes
bishop
okay so first knight takes bishop no no
no i'm thinking queen's player forward
first but an idea and another tactical
idea that that's kind of a little bit
hidden is knight takes bishops here you
would just have to figure out what
no i i didn't see that sorry okay so
maybe similar idea but just a different
order maybe you can take the bishop
first and after rook takes then you can
think about your move to ivanka so
hitting uh the knight with your rook
hitting it with the queen as well a
double attack and for example if the
knight just moves out the way then
suddenly discovered attack bishop takes
pawn check looking for checks first in
every single position and suddenly the
black rook is undefended and might fall
off the board i don't think this quite
works because in this position black can
deal with both of those threats against
his knight and against this rook in one
move black can offer a trade of queens
potentially
just defending everything i don't see a
knockout blow here for white but this is
the type of thing that eric will be
looking for
and i'm just wondering first thing i'm
drawn to uh as simon mentioned when you
have this pawn that's the signal to try
and attack uh and you use that kind of
to support pieces jumping forward maybe
you could at some point think of jumping
a knight i don't think i don't think
this works right now but maybe you can
prepare it the rook is attacked after
all maybe just bring your rook to the
side and uh i mean there's knight on f
to g5 which is quite interesting i'm
just going to throw throw that one in if
you take the rook then i play you try
your move you know this could lead to
absolute chaos you you then bring the
knight inward check
and uh the queen if if it's captured
flies it's a very nice check mate if the
king goes to the side there a beautiful
a beautiful two night check mate so you
probably have to accept this yeah he
dodges the check then whoops oops yeah
that's a nice nice cheeky two-night one
really rough
but this is the kind of thing you you go
for right if you're in a must-win
situation well okay why not and you
might have one attacker two attackers
three attackers the black king looks
pretty lonely out there on its own it's
still not 100 clear whether this works
maybe the black king can start making a
mad dash
for the center for safety and you've
sacrificed a lot of material here a rook
and a piece down and that's why eric is
calculating right now he's actually
played really quickly up to this point
still with over 10 minutes left and he
has stopped at the critical moment when
the evaluation bar has jumped up
he's calculating this night check he's
calculating this knight jumping forward
he's calculating as ivanka mentioned
maybe taking this bishop off or pushing
the queen forward so so many options but
what is the best move
if if nothing else works very minimum i
think he should move this rook out the
way i'm not sure exactly where maybe to
attack black's bishop or centralize it
and i don't think geary can actually get
okay he does capture the bishop i was
gonna say i don't think gary can get
greedy because there would be some
sneaky ideas of knights jumping forward
tactics like this one but okay this is
the position we mentioned this uh ivanka
this was your instinct and now black
maybe only has one move yeah but your
move is a great move you know it just
completely neutralizes
all
the tactical ideas that i had and uh
suddenly i don't think there's not much
in it for white anymore yeah the queen
trade if the queen's come off the board
we're heading towards a draw and giri
will win today's match so i think giri
needs to find this move but it's process
of elimination there's not much else the
knight is attacked after all by white's
rook and queen and uh you do need to
defend this rook which is loose whose
pieces drop off
uh so yeah you can deal with that with
one move trade the queens
and geary should be edging towards
safety eric paused at the right moment
the critical moment but he still has 10
minutes maybe he could have invested
another three or four
uh to find a way to keep the tension
indonesia only needs a draw to win the
match four players have already finished
their matches and look at that it's a
really good atmosphere out in the lounge
magnus is hanging out having some of
that fantastic sushi
jordan is playing it looks like he's
having a great time
and we also see jacob he's our social
media chief having a great time we see
han sebastian he's the second
in this tournament for jordan from
forest
that looks uh that looks really nice i
want to go out there and have some sushi
yeah i'm pretty sure eric and anisha are
going to join them yeah no matter the
outcome of their match today
and yeah the sushi the bonus
fantastic and do you think these two
will be heading out to the lounge quite
soon or or is there chances for eric to
fight fight fight for a win
it's gonna be difficult after that queen
move i feel but
eric he wants to go down fighting uh
also all of the chess bro fans they're
going to be watching this game from afar
he knows he's got their uh their support
so he'll want to give them a show and a
draw is the same as the loss here pretty
much
and why not why not go for the win yeah
why not take risks or yeah at least try
something later i'm wondering why anish
has taken his time is it possibly that
night comes in the middle did you look
at that here is that the only try i mean
because you have to try something as
risky as is can you move your knight
he's played the move that uh we we're
worried if you're an er you know eric
fan but can the knight at least come in
now try that
maybe you have to try something like
that right so blocking the trade of
queens by planting the knight in the
middle of this diagonal and the tension
between the queen's just too much right
now if you don't play this the problem
is that black is attacking your bishop
with his rook black's bishop is pointing
down at the white knight
yeah just too many problems and
maybe alright simon maybe that's what
white needs to do maybe you have to try
it i mean for better or worse you gotta
because if white can play two moves like
move the knight and push that pawn again
in the center of the board or do
something similar then white white's
attack is is still going uh but um
it's quite hard to get two moves and a
rose in it and a game of chess so
unfortunately you know especially in the
uh esports arena out there we do obey
the rules so two moves in a row
i get caught out and uh anisha's so
strong as well i mean he's he's a very
experienced fighter we should mention as
well we do have on-site arbiters so
if the players do try anything a bit
sneaky like that the artists might step
in yeah
and uh i do have to share with you
two funny tweets by valentino
and uh valentino says that they're
looking forward to simon williams new
playlist ginger gm's 80s cheesy
cheesy chest tunes
oh yeah i'm not really into my cheesy
music i have to say it's not i mean not
really
not really me but uh
you know i can't i mean
i'm trying to think about can you
imagine you as a dj
welcome
to cheesy
and
yeah they also say that they're also
looking forward to your new book
charlie's fighting chess for cool cats
well that's
possible possible i'd like to highlight
your description of what happened to
charlie yeah yeah he's doing well cat
fighting chess yeah yeah yeah
well not i don't know it doesn't feel
like a cat fight yet in this game eric
hanson fighting hard to find a win the
same situation in the other game going
on liam leahy has to win game four
against shakhtar al-mamdiarov to take it
two tie breaks i i will be very
surprised if we have
no tie breaks on the first day that
would be a huge shock actually yeah it
would be surprising but we have been
surprised actually by the lack of tie
breaks because uh so far this season
there's been one one time right between
duda and magnus carlsen and the final
so
that was the final of the charity cup so
yeah incredible stuff so and we've also
seen here a lot of decisive games yeah
because that must be
the reason we're just seeing a lot more
decisive games yeah last season we had
the kind of traditional format with half
a point for a draw one point for a win
and lots of players just playing it safe
just not taking too many chances and
especially in the prelims and maybe that
just continued into knockout phases and
we saw tie breaks galore which was
exciting as well but uh this season
players taking risks actually really
ambitious trying to win
uh in kind of normal times so yeah um
yeah herrick meanwhile he's got his head
down i'd be interested to see what his
facial expressions are to be honest
because i don't think he's happy maybe
he just missed this move this uh this
queen move otherwise he would have had a
reply prepared beforehand and so now
spending the time it might be too late
and uh yeah it's just hard if you keep
the queen's on risk is involved so i
mean if you do play knight d4 when he's
played it i think he has to play this
because everything else is
just bad i mean you're not you're not
going to win so you have to keep the
queens on uh i don't you know i mean
this is this is still fighting
um there's you know you need one more
move now
but
black yeah yeah this move can can really
change things around
uh black has a lot of decent moves here
though attacked the night with a work um
many other options as well yeah you
could attack the night with a rook
however simon may be here you could push
the pawn forward right and uh it's your
idea basically to break through to the
black king i don't think that really
wants to take this because suddenly
whoops the black king is really out in
the open and uh the whole idea is a
really beautiful one actually if you
take the night with the queen you just
ignore the tension with the queens you
just push forward with your pawn and
look at this checkmate on the board next
move background checkmate uh but yeah uh
you're right though a few moves this
looks super loose really loose here
these two pieces and
another option that maybe comes to mind
as you mentioned attacking the knights
is to trade off the knights and now this
night under fire also attention between
these rooks have been unleashed
these rooks disappear this is a very
good move isn't it you bring your worst
place piste into the game you try to
swap the pieces off rooks knights
they're all coming off and nish is so
good in these kind of positions i've
seen him do this many times before he
very rarely
you know blunders makes any mistakes and
he knows exactly what to aim for
involving small calculations with good
uh positional decisions so i think it's
looking very good for niche fans but not
so good for eric yeah and one thing i
was going to say as well when you're
when you're in that drawing mode you
tend to instinctively like offer pieces
for trade because you're hoping
for them to be swapped off so that you
can go to a simplified position and it
just so happens here that this is the
best move in the position it's what
needs to be done
and i i like the way that anish is
playing and
i don't see any way for eric to kind of
keep the game going actually apart from
yeah yeah i mean you have to take big
risks here but i don't think they'll pay
off uh apart from pushing this pawn
forward which doesn't work anymore
because now there's no rook to capture
or there's nothing to capture you can't
push forward because black actually
defends the promotion square of uh of
this white pawn uh so if this pawn push
doesn't work what else could you try you
could try stepping forward with the
queen lining up against this pawn
but uh after queen takes for example yes
you get one check yes you get two checks
but is it really enough you can capture
the black bishop but your own bishop
falls and here
you're attacking with one piece and one
piece isn't enough to win the game when
you attack this white rook is just a
bystander not participating so
all attacking options here just look
like they're
not quite working
yeah and what happens if you go
go for broke and you just step up the
queen i mean in this position yeah does
maybe go rick takes rick first okay
and uh
and now step up the queen but this is
the variation we just showed you sorry
sorry it takes night
uh yeah okay yeah it's just not quite
working it's one check it's two checks
but no more yeah yeah yeah i don't think
there's anything really is that
unfortunately i mean
yep i mean anisha is just too well
coordinated here uh with his work queen
yeah knight and uh he's going for it
like you say his last move was a natural
one to play and it's the best move and
he's making exchanges so um not really i
mean eric missed this
chance didn't he by swapping off his
dark square bishop it seems he had he
you know kept that bishop on the board
uh it would have given many more uh
attacking possibilities yeah bishop here
the black king would just be doomed yeah
yeah so this is where chess is so
difficult at times it's the right
decision to swap off those bishops and
other times it's the right decision to
build and uh
well
chess is hard this is the beauty of
chess you know every
every day you know you get a new game a
new position a new challenge and uh i
think someone said when they were
talking about video games that uh often
when you play these video games or
computer games you kind of get to the
top level and that's it you've completed
it
and with chess you never get there it's
always like infinite you're always
carrying it on i think that's the beauty
isn't it that no matter what level
you're at even magnus you know you can
get better you know you can always get
better even the best computers out there
they can get better so it's kind of a
game without any barriers really which
is
really like nothing else and isn't that
kind of like
the perfect move isn't always the
perfect move as well in a human game
because you want to play on the clock
you want to maybe play on the other
player's weakness
sometimes i mean magnus does this a lot
he doesn't play the best move yeah you
know he plays the second third best move
to get his opponent out of preparation
and then to you know get him into
territory where he can outplay them so
it's uh yeah i mean there's some
it's there's lots of different ways you
can do it and play so uh
look at that there's an air things
device in the oslo esports arena
and air quality very good for the
players
a little bit uh is that a bit lower high
humidity jamaica you're the air things
expert
19 percent i think it's a little bit low
but don't quote me on that i i would
imagine that you know it's not too humid
in a tv studio like that the thing is my
earthings device always tells me what to
do
because i have it on a little app and it
goes oh the humidity is low so i never
kind of pay attention to the numbers and
it goes you know have a shower open the
door yeah that's what it ends okay we
need to bring in the shower to the oslo
esports arena it tells you when to have
a shower no it it just it monitors the
air quality in my room
[Laughter]
it does measure like chemicals in the
air so you know right
you're getting attacked by chemicals
shower now
could be very useful with some chess
players after that story you told me the
other day
so
yeah
well i think in many settings it could
be nice if someone got a you know
have a shower you're in the office now
oh my gosh it's over
or they should make it voice activated
just to really embarrass the person
shower
now
alright well a free uh advice for air
thinks they're the next feature to have
in the fantastic everything's device
telling people to shower when they
should invoice in the post yes
meanwhile gary looking very very chilled
i've got to give him credit in this game
in the past maybe he's had an unfair
reputation for
maybe draws and things but that's only
because he's so good at safety first
chess he's so good at neutralizing the
opponent when he wants to
i mean nowadays he's much more attacking
more dynamic but um yeah he's closing in
on this uh this draw which will win him
today's match uh there's only been a
couple of moves white's rook swung
across to attack black bishop in the
corner and black's bishop just went to a
safe square and still the same problems
persist for hansen there's no way to
keep the knights on the board no way to
keep the queen's on the board and if
everything disappears a draw is the best
white can hope for also note how white's
back rank is slightly vulnerable
white's king doesn't have any escape
squares same for black's king and i
think that's the only thing that could
decide this game in either side's favor
is the fact that neither king has these
uh kind of hidey holes and uh therefore
backrack checkmate ideas are in the air
but uh yeah in general eric now under
one minute as well
it's looking like he's running out of
resources
and it's the kind of position where eric
is not going to be wanting a draw a draw
is the same as a loss so
he might just lose just because he
takes the wrong decision that's really
interesting actually he's clicked on his
knight but he hasn't chosen a square for
it so um is it touch
touch piece move a piece no touch piece
move
he trades the knights but it's
interesting that he clicked on his
knight and then the computer for you it
showed you the eight possible squares
the knight could use uh and it shows you
outside of system is the october that's
not very fair
helping you make legal moves
uh yeah so no outside assistance it
didn't tell you which nightmare was the
best there were eight possible night
moves in the end he traded off a set of
knights and now giri
is he going to keep the queens on the
board or is he going to just uh refuse
to capture that knight for now and trade
off do you think these players also have
that feature that
the king turns red if it's uh in check
oh interesting i don't have to zoom in
on the skates or something because i'm
very i'm i'm very happy to have that
feature when i play online chess because
i won't always see the check
uh but these players obviously will so i
don't know
most of the time yeah i have played
bullet chess one minute chess where you
just have to pre-move everything because
you don't have enough time on the clock
and i tried to make a move and i'm like
why isn't it letting me know and then i
realized oh whoops
that's a check
but uh yep gary here do you think he can
just trade the queens i think he can
probably if he wants to i mean
i guess
taking the night with a queen good move
taking the queens off good move yeah as
as we're saying you instinctively make
exchanges when you want to get a draw so
queen takes queen probably probably the
the first move you think of i mean maybe
some pawn could be one but yeah i was
going to say that
i mean do you allow white to win a pawn
just in financial simplification i think
it's a very easy draw if you do um
anyway and anisha's
brilliant endgame player and so he's
just thinking now i don't know how much
time he's well he's got lots of time so
he's making the right decision
deciding which way to go um to try and
get that draw
yeah so just to show maybe what is about
to happen and what anish is thinking
about right now it's two main options
either you can take this knife back with
your queen actually threatening a
checkmate along this diagonal the pawn
in front of white's king is under fire
and this looks pretty healthy as simon
mentioned also you've got a pin here i
don't think there's any real danger but
the queens are on and things bad things
can happen while the queens are on and
uh okay instead after knight takes night
he has indeed traded and as you guys
were mentioning white is about to win a
pawn because he can actually take this
guy and uh utilizing this idea i
mentioned earlier the background
checkmate black is doomed here you can
only throw pieces in the way but in this
position black will not take that he'll
just create a square for his king and
the game will end in a draw and we did
see two players leave the arena shakira
and mamjarov and liam lia they have
finished game four and they have
finished the match it is a draw and
chakra and mom giro he won game two and
he is the winner of that match gaining
three points and zero points for liam
lee in the first match he's going to
face magnus carlsen tomorrow so tough
start for liam le in the oslo esports
cup
and probably also for eric hansen if you
can find a win in this game and it's the
worst possible opponent to have to win
against and ishkiri is just an expert
in denying his opponent to win yeah
exactly and okay instead of pushing a
pawn in front of the black king he's
created an escape route for it by
marching it towards the center
white is a pawn up but look at those
white double d points yeah they're too
weak
one of those pawns will just drop and
it'll be three versus three there's a
saying all rook endings are drawn that
they're not but this one is
very very drawn all the poor there's no
past pawns there's not really there's
not really much going on is there
unfortunately for eric and uh eric only
has uh 18 seconds to boot so i mean if
the the roles were reversed the times i
mean and it was ghiru playing on 20
seconds maybe there's a chance but uh as
the time stands now
it's looking like 99 percent likely
that's going to finish in a draw and
he's winning that pawn back now and is
totally symmetrical yeah
any moment eric i think is just gonna
offer the draw because he wants to fight
to the death but there's nothing else to
do and there we go it is